adult film actress stormy Daniels could
have her hushed agreement with Donald
Trump nullified after the president
failed to sign the actual document that
means she can talk because he failed to
sign the document and if that happened
she could talk openly about her alleged
affair with President Trump now when you
think about it as well a lot of people
have said you really have to blame
Donald Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen for
the oversight you see Michael Cohen he
was the one that made the mistake he's
the lawyer he should have made sure that
didn't happen and Michael Cohen has made
other mistakes in handling this very
same situation we did some investigating
we found out for example apparently
Cohen's set up a limited liability
company to hide the source of the
payment check it out look at the name of
the company porn star that's not a good
name
look at this this was another mistake
that the lawyer made the check he used
for the payoff has a watermark in it of
trumpets for McDaniels in bed together
finally his biggest mistake was the
lawyer hired a skywriter skywriter to
send her a thank-you note it says thanks
stormy for keeping your mouth shut
Donald Trump's lawyer Michael Cohen
[Applause]
you